[Music]
what's up guys greg alba here i'm still
in recovery mode feeling a little bit
better today and i was like a little
bit's all i need to keep on filming all
I gotta do is take a couple of gummies
of something special to get you enough
energy to feel like filming for a little
bit you guys know what gummies I'm
talking about thanks California this
spot will be filled in a second they
make sure the mics off this way we're
gonna get out of the bathroom we're
gonna watch some alien covered in
trailers today the run the prey the hide
hey John I started filming without you
take a seat take a seat my friend I'm
pretty time sick - actually you're going
god I worth filming the only sick people
can always sick people get film together
today this is actually very action
that's why there's no hot girls in the
video it's just John and I so much to be
here everybody you had to sacrifice your
live
large-scale colonization mission and
everyone back on earth is really
grateful making history hey hey John
what I just realized what did you just
realized
wouldn't he see Billy Crudup yeah and it
says run yeah Billy Crudup is the father
of the flash in Justice League oh my god
that's oh my god no matter universes are
just getting bigger and bigger
mmm Batman thought predator yeah
Jesus fought Satan those are two very
different things crossover time alien
covenant
oh I heard there's one with like new
Mira pause it might be this one this is
a higher one by process of elimination
[Music]
whoa that was a different thing at the
Neo morph or whatever they're calling Oh
the thing from the end of her atheists
yeah it's like an upgraded version of
that oh that could be it cuz that was
not a xenomorph I've heard yeah it's a
Neil Worf according to comments on
YouTube boy a few other comments on
YouTube saying that it's not the Neo
morph you [ __ ] idiot those people
don't seem that they get the Neo morph
so we're gonna go with that the Neo more
it's a morph of some sort oh well I
guess that does give a little bit more
of a hint kind of I mean on thing into
that I mean she's supposed to be in here
yeah it looked like it's just like
Superman in the [ __ ] Justice League
trailer
no where's new I gotta say the new neo
morph looks a little ridiculous I can't
really tell what it looks like it kind
of looks like resident evil creature
yeah it kind of looks like an alien but
with like a testicle head and I only say
testicle head just because you know
these these HR Giger designs are pretty
reproductive in their design this I mean
you know face huggers I love how the
Prometheus sequel was a question of how
connected is this gonna be to alien and
now it's become how connected is this
gonna read it for me complete reversal
alien as [ __ ] is that the same neo morph
from the end of Prometheus just been
chillin hungry as [ __ ] waiting for
someone to beat up I mean from this
angle it doesn't look like it but I
can't tell cuz that that one and it at
the end of Prometheus had like a still
had that kind of like triangular kind of
conehead thing yeah maybe it's just the
perspective here you know what I gotta
say that I'm excited for Ridley Scott to
be doing with this at least he had the
great effect of the first alien where
you don't really see this you know
and I'm excited for him here to see how
he shows off the xenomorph more visual
you know stylistic wise because he
didn't really get a chance to do that
with alien obviously not prometheus
so here it's like a lot of the coolest
shots are like that's pretty sexy under
the xenomorph you know yeah and the prey
teaser with like the rain and everything
does the really sick job that is the
coolest shot that I've seen from any of
these ads actually like that was a
[ __ ] wicked looking yeah and and I
mean you know like these these ads don't
it's wage any of my worries about this
but like these are cool I like they're
playing up the terror of every yeah you
know cuz the first movie is so suspense
and so horror oriented and this looks
like horror but it also looks up
ggressive oh yeah and like that's cool
like I'm excited to see that no it's
cool to see like man we got like a legit
it looks like it's gonna be an OG sci-fi
horror film oh you know it's gonna have
the sci-fi and the horror all that once
and yeah I'm excited for that I feel
like we haven't gotten like a big like
sci-fi horror film definitely yeah yeah
you know on this scale especially yeah
I'm excited to see how I you know Billy
Crudup gets out of that sticky situation
oh yeah he's gonna be fine
definitely gonna be fine it's gonna be
fun trailers don't ruin anything you
know what I gotta say you know people
including us always say our trailers
ruin so much these days I'm gonna stop
saying these days if you watch trailers
from like the 70s in the 60s those
trailers ruined way more than what
trailers the date mothers take the BVS
second trailer that has nothing compared
to like any of the rocky treaters back
in the day so your sailors now will dip
too heavily in Act three perhaps there
are ones that are like three minutes so
it's like here's the plot beat by being
here all the important elements you need
to know and uh here's the arc you know
it's gonna turn out come soon so I like
teases like this a lot a lot
they're cool I'm excited to check this
out I mean like this is getting me
anticipating because there's a lot of
stuff to feel about this movie and the
thing is like that's at the point where
I don't care anymore I just want to see
it now yeah I just want to see it Ridley
Scott can be hit or miss sometimes now
and this is I've been very cynical about
this project but this looks really cool
just looking at these so I hope that
this is the movie that Prometheus wanted
to be listen no sarcasm here no satire I
will only go though if it has a good
score on Rotten Tomatoes as I base all
my viewing experiences off of what
Rotten Tomatoes says in today's
fast-paced world there's a lot to think
about and it can be cumbersome thinking
for yourself which is why I try to do
that as seldom as possible and Rotten
Tomatoes really helps me out with that
when it comes to motion pictures so
let's just hope that Rotten Tomatoes
gives us some a good score else it'll
definitely not be getting my ticket dude
why don't we try and predict the tomato
meter score all right
121 percent 68 hmm
you might be closer you know really
Scott brings back some the horrific
stylings that maybe you know loved but
uh still some awesome hollows too or
even are in the in the script it still
lacks a compelling story at the center
of it all I hope Danny McBride lives
subscribe to the real rejects jaws
reason tsageri on twitter and instagram
social media manager of Blum house and
the real rejects and shout out to
hashtag Danny McBride lives that's what
everyone's gonna be saying by the time
they watch this movie hell he's gonna be
like when Frodo lived after you washed
off